hi i'm dr jeffrey iliff a sleep
researcher today we're going to be
answering your questions on twitter this
is shh
this is sleep support
[Music]
at cattywampus it's 5am i can't sleep
i'm eating summer sausage what is time
what are circadian rhythms well i don't
know why you're eating summer sausage at
5 a.m what are circadian rhythms i can
answer that circadian rhythm is the
drive in your body that entrains all of
its functions to the 24-hour light cycle
so there's a part of your brain called
the supercharismatic nucleus that's the
master pacemaker for the circadian
rhythm and what it does is it cues off
of the light dark cycle so sunrise and
sunset to get your brain and actually
the rest your body ready to rest at
night and ready to act during the day
at rg will underscore asks why do we
take naps and wake up more tired oh
that's a good question because there's
good napping and there's bad napping
when you wake up after a nap and you
feel like you just got hit by a truck
it's because what has happened is you
started to build what's called sleep
inertia so once you start sleeping after
you get past a certain point your brain
gets into the mode that thinks oh we're
doing this for the next eight hours and
if you interrupt it after it's gotten
past that point it's sort of a rude
awakening and that's why you feel super
groggy after a long nap that's why when
you nap you should actually nap either a
very short nap maybe 20 or 30 minutes or
90 minutes so setting an alarm for a 90
minute nap a 90 minute nap is enough
time for you to go through an entire
sleep cycle so going through shallow
sleep to deep sleep up to rem but only
once not long enough for you to build a
lot of sleep inertia but enough time for
you to actually get some of the benefits
of sleeping at punk ass book joke says
everybody talking about their weird
covered dreams and i'm over here like
lol what is rem sleep these are actually
eeg caps that measure your what's going
on inside your brain so that we can see
not just whether you're asleep but what
stages of sleep you happen to be in so
rapid eye movement sleep is the face of
sleep connected with dreams it has a
couple of weird features to it so in one
of the things if we record the
electrical activity happening in your
brain it actually looks a lot like an
awake brain in fact one of the only ways
that we can tell that you're in rem
sleep and not awake is one of these
electrodes here actually connects to the
muscles on your face and so we can
actually detect the tension or the
absence of tension in your face muscles
and that's how we know you're in rem
sleep not just laying there awake so
during rem sleep what's happening is
your brain is working to consolidate the
memories that you form through the
course of the day helping to harden
those memories into your long-term
memory things that are powerful things
that are fearful things that are scary
things that create anxiety all of those
things are the substance of our dreams
that's part of the way that you encode
dreams is with fear and pain and emotion
so it's probably no wonder that we're
all having the same weird covet dream
at rusty covey asks how will your brain
get rid of waste it isn't sent back into
the body to be processed by the organs
how does your sleep play a role in it
this is a really interesting question
it's actually the subject that my lab
studies so your brain is very different
from the rest of the body in the way
that it manages the waste so the brain
sits in a pool of water called cerebral
spinal fluid and that water helps to
cushion the brain from blows that happen
and actually helps the the brain which
has the kind of the consistency of room
temperature butter it helps it to not
you know slouch under its own weight
during the day time the spaces between
the brain cells which are like the pores
of this sponge are actually pretty small
and pretty narrow so as a result the
water that's outside the brain sort of
sits on the outside but when you go to
sleep the situation completely changes
and the spaces between the brain cells
open up allowing the water that's on the
outside of the brain to actually wash
into and through the spaces between the
brain cells collecting up the waste
that's accumulated through the course of
the waking day and so then this waste
laden fluid like ammonia that's produced
washes out of the brain out into the
fluid around the brain and then those
lymphatic vessels surrounding the brain
collect it up and eventually dump it
back into the blood it's like
brainwashing but without being in an
occult
at kbraham 21 asks have you ever
wondered what your brain actually looks
like when you sleep
like i wonder if my neurons are really
just beating the snot out of each other
and my dreams are the real reason i'm
losing brain cells i don't think dreams
are the reason you're losing brain cells
you can actually see your brain when
it's sleeping you can see it by mri
sometimes you can see it during
neurosurgical procedures the thing about
the brain that's really striking is the
way that it pulsates so the brain is
just this big pulsating mass of tissue
and blood so you see it pulsating with
the heart rate and you see it pulsating
and swelling with the respiratory cycle
and there's actually these even low
frequency oscillations that happen as
blood vessels in the brain dilate and
contract those pulsations are actually
part of the process driving the
clearance of waste into and out of the
brain at fxmish asks does anyone that
can lucid dream have any tips on how to
do it so lucid dreaming think the movie
inception is being aware of the fact
that you're dreaming when you are so
that you can control what's happening
around you it's a little fringy but
there's actually a little bit of
research on the subject so there's some
data that suggests that you can use
transcranial electrical stimulation so
stimulating your brain with electricity
at certain frequencies can increase the
likelihood that a person who normally
can't lucid dream actually can be able
to there's also some approaches in
sleeping itself that seems to increase
people's ability to lucid dream you set
an alarm for five hours after you go to
sleep and then wake up right after you
wake up you think to yourself i'm going
to be dreaming i want to wake up during
my dream repeat that to yourself again
and again and again as you go back to
sleep your chances of go being able to
know that you're in a dream when you go
back into sleep actually increase
between a hundred percent to a thousand
percent so it may be either through
stimulation or maybe through some
cognitive tricks you can actually
increases your chances of being able to
lucid dream
caramel cookie asks so it's like
sleepwalking a real thing yes
sleepwalking is a real thing so
sleepwalking is more common in kids and
in adolescents it tends to disappear as
people move through adolescence into
adulthood the interesting thing about
sleep sleepwalking is that your brain is
asleep and yet you can accomplish very
complicated tasks so when you're
sleeping your brain is supposed to be a
little bit disconnected from your
awareness and it's supposed to be
disconnected from how your body moves
sometimes those connections they can get
opened or they can get closed at the
wrong time so you see things like sleep
talking or sleep moaning you see people
who have something called rem sleep
behavior disorder which is where you
actually act out the things that are
happening in your dreams sometimes even
violently sometimes injuring your bed
partner so there's a bunch of different
types of things some of them interesting
some of them a little scary that can
happen when the processes governing
sleep and your body
become misaligned at swank farm asks how
many types of sleep do we have you
actually see that your brain is doing a
couple of distinct things through the
course of the night one set of that is
called rem sleep or rapid eye movement
sleep and that's the part of sleep
that's most associated with with
dreaming there's also non-rem sleep
non-rem sleep sort of breaks into three
different categories there's n1 and 2
and m3 and one is the shallowest type of
sleep so that's maybe the first 10
minutes after you first fall asleep and
that's the time when you're sort of most
awake it's easy to sort of pop back up
away and to sleep is sort of the mid
layer on your way to deep sleep during
that phase you're a little deeper in and
your body starts to actually do some
funny things so that's when sometimes
people twitch and move a little bit
during n2 sleep the deepest sleep is
called n3 sleep or slow wave sleep and
during that time if we record what's
happening in your brain your brain is
actually oscillating between states
where everything's on and everything's
off and it's doing those oscillations
about one every second those are called
slow oscillations that slow wave sleep
is the deepest part of sleep and then
you'll come back up into rem sleep where
you'll typically do dreaming one of
those cycles is about 90 minutes or so
during the course of the night you go
through several of those cycles maybe
three or five of them later on in the
night there's less slow wave sleep and
more ram which is one of the reasons why
maybe we remember the dreams that we're
having late in the night better
atmoniagre asks what is sleep apnea i
would have asked google but i prefer a
more simple answer sleep apnea is a
condition where you stop breathing
several times through the course of the
night so it can actually be a physical
obstruction to your airway that keeps
you from sleeping regardless of the
cause the result's bad your brain is
incredibly active so the the neurons in
your brain are firing trillions and
trillions of times a second and all of
that activity takes a huge amount of
oxygen and glucose and energy to keep it
going and every time you stop breathing
during the night you're depriving your
brain for just a little while of the
energy that it needs and of the oxygen
that it needs and it isn't until your
brain is screaming for more oxygen that
you actually gasp yourself away and as
you add that up over the course of many
nights over weeks and months and years
the added stress that that puts on not
just your brain but actually your whole
body can increase your risk of
cardiovascular disease like heart
attacks and strokes diabetes the good
news is that sleep apnea much of it is
actually pretty treatable with an
approach called cpap which is basically
just a mask that goes over your face and
it uses a little pump to sort of force
air in and out and the forcing that air
in and out of you out of your lungs
helps to keep your airway open and keep
you from stopping breathing during the
night the bad news is
many more of us actually have sleep
apnea than know it what does it look
like how do i know if i have sleep apnea
well common symptoms include heavy
snoring waking up gasping if that sounds
like you might be worth getting checked
out with your physician athalia clara
asks what causes insomnia because i
literally cannot go to sleep at a decent
time no matter how tired i am upside
down smiley upside down smiling upside
down smiley well insomnia is pretty
common so it's not being able to either
go to sleep or it's not being able to
stay asleep once you are asleep there
are genetic causes of insomnia sleep
apnea can cause insomnia but frequently
it's the stress in our lives that can
cause either acute insomnia which is
insomnia that just happens every so
often or chronic insomnia that happens
all the time so things that are
important for sleep hygiene include
going to sleep at the same time every
day and waking up at the same time every
day so that your body can entrain to a
certain rhythm that can become
predictable it's staying off the screens
for an hour before you go to bed it's
sleeping in a cool dark room where that
isn't also your office so that you can
sort of sort of focus in on the process
of either having sex or going to sleep
which is really the only two things you
should be doing in your bedroom
atmashcelelo asks what causes sleep
paralysis had it twice last night
scream emoji that sounds like kind of a
rough night sleep paralysis is when
you're laying in bed you're sort of
coming out of sleep or sometimes it's
when you're going into sleep you're
aware of your environment around you you
perceive what's happening but you can't
move the rest of your body you're sort
of paralyzed and sometimes it can be
accompanied by visual or auditory
hallucinations or feelings of fear or
tear or even feelings of suffocation so
it can be completely terrifying your
body has a couple of disconnect switches
that it throws so that all the activity
happening in your brain while you're
dreaming or during your rem sleep
doesn't cause you to act out your
actions in the world around you in sleep
paralysis those disconnect switches seem
to get a little jumbled up so that the
switch that disconnects you from
awareness of your of your environment
sort of gets opened so you become aware
even while the switch disconnecting you
from your body is still closed if we do
an eeg study in people who are having
sleep paralysis episodes we actually
seem that they still seem to be in rem
sleep so even though while you're aware
of what's around you your brain is still
dreaming and your body still thinks
you're asleep it's just that you're
stuck feeling awake
at yatu sabes who asks how do sleeping
pills work it depends a little bit on
the sleeping pills that you're talking
about so let's start with the simpler
ones so a lot of people take melatonin
to help them sleep melatonin is actually
a naturally occurring molecule in your
body that is part of how the body
induces drowsiness it's actually a part
of the circadian sleep drive to help
sort of prime the brain to get ready to
sleep other commonly used sleep
medications include
drugs called sedative hypnotics like
ambien which is a commonly used one and
also benzodiazepines which are sort of
anti-anxiety medications that can be
used sometimes to help with sleep those
drugs are very powerful drugs they're
available only by prescription they have
the potential for forming addiction and
for habit forming so they need to be
used under the supervision of of a
physician they work by
targeting a neurotransmitter system in
the brain which dampens down neural
activity and to reduce arousal in the
brain to help you sleep many of the
sleep medications don't produce the same
type of natural cycling of sleep that
your brain wants so if you suffer from
an insomnia or if you have other sleep
issues other approaches like improving
your sleep habits or even cognitive
behavioral therapy can be actually more
helpful in helping your brain to sleep
naturally than trying to accomplish that
with the drug at talia glasgow asks is
it really true that you can never catch
up on sleep if yes i'm actually so
[ __ ] well you kind of are the sleep
that you lose is sort of gone forever
and many of the benefits of that sleep
whether that's memory consolidation or
whether that's the rejuvenation that
happens in the brain you sort of miss
the boat but there is something that
builds up the longer your sleep and the
less sleep that you get that's called
sleep debt and what sleep debt is is the
drive to sleep more that builds through
the course of the day and it builds with
sleep restriction and so when you go to
sleep that sleep that is relieved and
sort of paid off so there is a sense in
which you can catch up on sleep an
interesting study that was measuring
waist clearance out of the brain showed
that if a person was kept up all night
the slowing of brain clearance that
happens in a person who stays up all
night actually it took seven days for it
to catch up so even the second day after
the sleep deprivation it hadn't even
caught up so you don't necessarily catch
up on lost sleep within a day or two it
may take much longer
at ferlingberg asks how long does coffee
affect your sleep system the answer is
that it's longer than most people think
so the active ingredient in coffee is
caffeine which targets a receptor in the
brain that helps to turn off neurons and
so by blocking that receptor it turns on
neurons that's how coffee has its main
effect on on you being awake now the
half-life of coffee in the blood is
between four and six hours which means
it takes the better part of half a day
for it to clear out of your body so if
you want to not have caffeine
influencing your sleep when you go to
bed you probably need to be stopping
drinking caffeinated coffee or other
drinks like monster or these other
energy drinks probably around two or
three in the afternoon one of the things
that caffeine does is it sort of keeps
your brain aroused it keeps your brain
awake maybe not all the way away because
so you might be skimming through the
shallow parts of the shallow phases of
sleep and not getting into those really
deep phases of sleep that are necessary
for brain health
at lindsay chat asks would love to get
your tips on how to handle jet lag what
do you find effective one approach is
ahead of your trip if you can do this if
your schedule allows you you can start
moving your sleep wake cycle back an
hour a day so that by the time you leave
you're within an hour or two of your
target time zone so if you're going to
europe and it's a six hour difference
six days ahead start moving your time to
go to sleep ahead one hour one hour one
hour so that by the time you leave
you're going to bed at 6 pm but the good
news is by the time you get into europe
jet lag will be smaller at that juan
pablo how do you track your sleep of
course most of us don't have eeg systems
in your house unless you're some kind of
weirdo so most of us use an approach
called actigraphy to measure our sleep
and so that's like your apple watch or a
fitbit and what that does is it it's
measuring your movement and inferring
from
your motion it's good at detecting when
you're in bed when you're asleep it's
not as good as detecting what kind of
sleep you're in so when your apple watch
tells you or your fitbit tells you well
i had this much deep sleep
maybe you did maybe you didn't but in
terms of knowing how much sleep you're
getting which is probably the more
important thing it's actually pretty
good for that at bikie84 asks ran on
four hours of sleep going to sleep to
wake up in two hours are there negative
effects of lack of sleep was that a
dancing bear it probably wasn't a
dancing bear that was probably the
visual hallucinations from you not
sleeping enough the human brain needs
seven to nine hours of sleep for adults
kids need more teenagers they seem to
need a lot more if you don't get enough
sleep if you go a night without sleep we
can actually measure deficits in your
memory in your attention in your
processing and response speed and in
your decision making so your lack of
sleep you know that it affects how you
feel today and tomorrow but there's
emerging data that suggests that
long-term lack of sleep or long-term
poor sleep may actually be setting the
the stage for chronic diseases like
diabetes or heart disease or even
cancers some pretty recent data suggests
that actually poor sleep especially in
mid-life may be setting the stage for
risk for developing dementia later on in
life in your 60s 70s and 80s so how you
treat your brain today may be
influencing the mind that you get to
have in 20 or 30 years
at last moonicorn asks if dreams are
your brain trying to sort out memories
and information while you sleep or work
through general data what is my brain
doing why is it creating places i
totally forget when i wake up but in my
dreams it's like i have my own separate
memory so all of us have sort of these
uncanny dreams that are weird mishmashes
of beluga whales you know disneyland
vacations and our mother-in-law so
what's going on there one of the things
that the brain might be doing is it's
actually using our memories putting them
together to try to generate new insights
and that maybe it's that that sort of
novel recombination process is where
human creativity and maybe even human
inspiration comes from in terms of why
you don't remember it maybe it's a
little bit like your laptop the way that
it does disc maintenance during the
night so while it's doing its
defragmentation the screen's off the
keys aren't lit but it's because
that's something that's for the computer
it's not for you the user it's not for
the outside world at an amnesis 80 says
you know what bugs me
why do we need to sleep i mean i know
the biology behind it but why what's the
purpose of sleep well first i have to
say that you probably don't know the
biology behind sleep if you're asking
this question but you shouldn't feel bad
because the reality is we really don't
understand completely why it is that we
sleep we have some hints so at a
cellular level though we see that some
interesting things are happening so the
brain is made up of trillions of
connections between all the nerve cells
those connections are your motions
they're your thoughts they're your
memories and you're making new
connections constantly but some of those
connections are important the
connections like how do i get away from
a saber-toothed tiger but some of those
are less important like the 19th cat
video that you watched on youtube last
night and so if your brain kept all the
connections every single day it would
become this clogged up rat's nest of
information and connection so you'd
never be able to think your way through
anything so during sleep connections
that are important the ones that are
connected to emotions or that are
powerful those actually firm up and the
ones that are less important the weak
ones actually get trimmed away there's
actually cells in your brain that eat
the extra connections while you're
asleep and so if you don't sleep those
processes of firming up and of pruning
don't get to happen which is why we
think it has such an important role in
memory all right so those are all the
questions for the day there are some
really awesome ones out there the big
takeaway is your brain needs sleep to be
healthy and it wants to sleep our job as
sleepers is to try to get out of the way
try to set the stage for it to do the
thing that it wants to do thank you for
watching sleep support